[Music] citizens of the reject Nation I
am dragging this out till we get to the
15-second mark so that way you can get away with
a slight inappropriate language I feel like I'm
almost there with a little warning bumper sign
just a gentle press there's something I got to
say and that is America's ass t-shirt that
is America's ass real reject exclusive over
at www.re naations shop.com is now available
and I just got mine in the mail and of course
we offer a whole bunch of other te's over
there as well one of the absolute best ways
to support the channel CO's got a nip chills
one on with M got this R real reject R thank
you guys so much who have been buying shirts
we have been having the best sales ever and
whenever I see that it happens it makes me so
happy because you're creatively involved with
them so thank you guys like I came up with this
one myself so thank you ah we're going to watch
genv episode 7 today I'm very excited excited are
you guys excited verily in general fly ladies and
Gentlemen please go ahead leave a like on
this video that'd be very much appreciated
also subscribe click the notification Bell to
get notified when our reaction for the finale
is up here on the Chanel full link 3 AC watch
along where you snle with your own copy with
jmv available for super sex re at our patreon
page I'm sing the brightness up on the TV I'm
not ignoring the camera cover sever things over
there how let's watch long as CL let's get to
it off me get the off me man
uhoh what I do oh my God it's it's it's our friend
is that really him it's movie Man mark it is movie
Man Mark no he's climbing up in the world what did
he do though I don't care okay he's a dude he's
been on this channel before yeah whoa rejects
gen V Cannon confirmed last of us crossover
Andy oh
no it's going to explode I have a feeling
sheno Conor and movie Men Mark are not long
for this world they are not they are moments
away how long will it take well transmission
occurs through direct contact with bodily fluids
so depending on Andy's viral Lo can't we make it
Airborne yeah speed it up if an Airborne virus
gets into the Super abled population it could
sprad like wildfire that's the point that's
kind of her goal here guy kill them all kill
them all VA would want us to entertain anything
so reckless in dea it's a little late in the day
to worry about what VA wants Edison that's what
leads to your death oh by the end of the episode
or the next 10 minutes next episode okay I
need to see you what's wrong with something
happened everything is just so up right now go
to my house fix yourself something to eat I'll
be there soon and I'll take care of everything
you're taking medication today yeah take another
the medication is keeping her under control
take three and call me in the morning let it
dull you we need to and be able to embrace
these powers without the medication what if
she's actually protecting us the paranoia is
so palpable Victor new protest leading up to
today's town hall with the historically unpopular
and phony socialist just as new rumors serving
Marvel's new rumors so what do we do I'll wait
for her at her house and then when she comes
home I'll make her tell everyone everything
this is Snappy to go run back to [__] you
let her go alone she'll just stab Us in the
back we trust her when she's still guys so
she can actually read their thoughts in real time
stay out of her heads damn do you know what I'm
thinking I didn't know that like K does sound
very far away right now thought it was a romantic
gesture you know what I'm thinking you know she
probably can't help it why are you making excuses
for what a beautiful shot we have to believe she's
on our side ads propaganda politics and genv and
you got to stop turning into a dude when you want
to make a point to us stop using the patriarchy to
your own Advantage kiss I said kiss you're halfway
there come on cuties yeah I smack Marie's ass and
then change and smack it again America's ass
she's the only way to get Shetty to expose the
woods unless we get proof ourselves how shed's in
the city all day I got the key to her office no
it's going to go great unless we get it to someone
they will listen to like Victoria Newman oh [__]
[__] yeah soup lives matter the editing already
is just so much like it's good commentary isn't
it guys it's a technical term I learn found
assessment I did Rip an entire person in half
my defense he was a puppet at the time so did
he get a haircut but maybe you didn't do that
because now I'm destroying the evidence and who
remembers yes I saw Starlight pretty sure there
it is yep it's time for pleasure okay that is a
normal am of toys true I like options respect we
should add stuff like that to the reject Nation
shop a personal vibrating wand that's just nipple
CH do not answer the door no matter what Strang
or danger stranger stranger danger that would be
my superhero name stranger danger I ship them so
hard so broke and cute it's a good thing you ship
them because they're together they are but I buy
it more than most TV couples okay I just you know
longevity ship I believe in it perpetually
till death do them part which I fear is
coming that some attention filled music right
there oh secret drawer blue bad blue bad this
was hidden in her drawer the Atlantic Flight
oh no the homelander one oh yeah one of the
most ghoulish moments in TV history yeah I
remember that it's terrorist right she has
evidence that it was homelander who did this
shedy Lily aged 11 oh her parent aged 46 her
family was on the plane yeah lifelong
Vengeance [Music] yep shitty shitty
shitty great cut you want me to increase
the viral infection rate let me anday my
plans allow Like a Villain hey man kill
them all J alcohol is the greatest plot
device yes let's go oh no golly it's gross
but people pretend it's good to
seem sophisticated mhm mhm find
vintage hey just handed them exactly what
they need what did he say about infection
rate there's a Sinister Bill to all this I think
there's a lot of gray framing in this particular
episode yeah yeah I wonder who directed this it's
been really solid the edit too you're right the
shows always have this blue aesthetic but it's
especially you know some powerful [Music] people
a CH with a celebrated bot psychologist who's now
dean of their little superhero Factory you got 2
minutes you'll want longer that's a good line
I'm sorry this is at the school and V doesn't
know we're estimating about 10 months to make it
potent and contagious enough to get the job done
it's getting harder to hide that's why I need
you what is your plan here I know you monitor
soups team affiliations their whereabouts you
know where to find all of them even those that
aren't under V's thumb okay take them all
out neiz them once and for all what you're
describing goes beyond neutralizing genocide
yeah full it's genocide you need to stop what
you're doing immediately none of this is going
to bring your husband and daughter back boom so
she's been playing this like ultimate long game
Revenge plan yeah oh your grandchildren oh one
of your fellow countrymen although I doubt you
travel in the same circles has this same rage
who is she talking about is there an angry
man we know from this universe have a coat
and a best beard on TV together we can end it or
I could have you arrested and I don't think you
will part of you agrees with me we're done here
wait pleasure to meet you Dean Shetty go back to
your school what an interesting flip because
it's like she's been poised as the villain
this whole time and while she's done some very
villainous activities the greater good of like
her loss we know the soups are awful so it's like
we kind of pulling for that there is a complexity
oh keep a close eye on her is that butcher think
it's butcher think it's GNA tie into season 4 I
told you think the finale is goingon to be a big
old collab I wanted you to know that I was good
today little tiny ones a don't be
creepy man it's so funny oh my God
so badass you just think that cuz I'm strong and
mistreated Emma oh no give me a hand uhoh
oh no no stranger danger no fun Steve it's
melting get back inside bro get back inside
dang AR aren't you going to get in trouble
we're superheroes we can do whatever we want
Magic's loud at Hogwarts that door locks bro
oh he's got a damn video don't no kill them all
yes oh it's that guy no no no no no no no no no
no no no no don't let him touch you oh no I
am so concerned right now me too don't love
this part's moving I'm coming I'm supposed
to stay here to uh to wait for Emma Emma's
at the party we're going to oh this is a big
con game this is a big manipulation game come
on oh just keep America safe hat okay no there
he is don't make this political show political
excuse me excuse me this kid is very much not
an Aryan propaganda this is not Tucker Carlson
no not at all what he talking about why is he on
Cameron Coleman he doesn't have anything new to
push until next year moderating the Newman thing
shedy thought it would look better if an actual
superhero was asking questions about superhero
issues what does that mean you know when I was a
kid I want wanted to be just like him but after
everything we know about this place you can't
trust them can't trust your own DAV then I'm just
going to tell Shetty everything you tell me Kate
you're the one on my head well Cameron we hear
like aulan believe that speech aggressive cut
little bit of overlap in the voice over a super
power whoa you meant super soldier a weird moment
tough questions the superheroes and real americ
she controlling him from there what's happening
this
who cover up $250 per month there are no
up what was the commercial even even now
I don't trust her I need to buy that you
are going to [Music] love [Music] Samuel
sh sh time to be a hero yeah my
that's my dad Buckle in we got to
get going where's Powers just going out
of control I couldn't tell or is it the
Airborne virus or was somebody in there
something yeah at first I thought it was
Emma I think it's the
virus his Towers it's p he's like
sick who whoa oh man treating
people with powers like that
oh oh jeez we need to wake him [Music] up that
woman is getting her ass kicked yeah seriously
she's going to get ripped apart shut up I thought
you said Emma was here what the oh she's meeting
us later why bring here oh the fbsa is here to
protect people from superheroes but at your own
Congressional hearing Stormfront slaughtered
multiple people and on a separate occasion
Soldier Boy nearly killed thousands of innocent
people in Manhattan why were you just sitting
back snapping your gum watching America burn good
questions both those instances caused a 30% drop
of public confidence in superhumans and the fbsa
responded by actually strengthening protection of
both humans and superhumans alike leading to a
record low number of violent incidents in both
populations well done around the Tire crowd got to
find Newman tell her what we know any chance you
know a teleporter no but I can cause a distraction
Jordan what are you going to do don't get caught
yank the tail that girl has just been a plot
device every time you're the girl who tortured
Emma right no no no no no I just gave her a plat
God every time that's what I'm talking about
amazing oh yeah oh wow superhero fight
hey break it up yeah get in there
[Music] bud I would get so distracted by
the distraction I would forget that I have
to sneak in there I have this job to do but
we all saw homelander kill a human in broad
daylight talking about it is he going to be held
accountable the finale is getting brought up now
homelander should stand trial just like anybody
else and a jury of his peers will deide that
outcome humans aren't our peers yeah buddy most
superhumans are law-abiding citizens n you don't
know [__] we can find Common Sense Solutions
here you will not control us BL heads up this is
not about control it's right right look people are
passionate about the issue so am I wow powered mob
why is everyone so angry because they're trying to
limit us take away our power we're homelander is
[Music] right the the syllables here miss Newman
um do you have a minute Miss Newman please it's
important that I speak with you you're Marie
morau right oh my God is she the one is she
the one who's the better she must be she must
be let's find some place we can chat just 100%
damn inside source damn I guess it was John
Carlo but John Carlo represented Victoria yeah
it's Victoria got to be jump am I I drank beer
there is this there was this ice slide I wish
you'd seen it and some of the people here are
bag but they're my friends now we got to hide
you it's okay we just got to hide you oh no he
feels accepted oh yeah bye best friends oh no
totally not manipulating me no don't forget where
you came from dude I've been trying to call you
for hours I'm sorry my meeting went long Kate
don't do anything rash Kate gloves are off not
been taking your medication Kate you know what
happens when you don't all those pills ever did
was make me numb you talk manipulate that's all
you've ever done to me that isn't true I'm glad
you're taking a stand but don't kill her yet
it's almost time to leave this place you're
leaving me no like the Mortal coil this place we
are leaving after I've tied up a few loose ends
then all of the sacrifices all of the hard work
she's tricking you don't trust her that's that
manipulation you're talking about you want to
make us sick you no I'm going to keep you safe
don't let her do it every day I ask myself why am
I still here I found something truly special again
a girl who was just as lost and lonely as I felt
oh God she so wants to believe in good oh what do
I what do I believe yeah I don't trust her she
she doesn't love her no she's lying everyone's
full of [__] don't do it you're telling the
truth she can read her mind the things my true
but I don't think one last push from you and
then we can leave all of this behind you will
never be alone again just kill your friends
Kate yes just one last time we'll hide out
in the green room until it all blows over out
there otherwise I think they might take off my
head that's a reference tell me something about
myself I don't understand you
can sense things and [Music]
blood
you're a super you're blood there's compound
V in it you're a soup I knew you could do it
good [Laughter] job why here give me a life
I love that was like a headless character
for transition clever oh yeah can she blood Bend
too that's how she blows people I let them ship
you after their adult facility so I got you
want to get F yep I know that you've fought
for every thing you've ever got in your life I
know that you're constantly lonely and you're
afraid that you're going to hurt people these
older women always generalizing her based off
the most obvious information I also know that
every Friday for the past eight years you've
had fish sticks with pink sauce As a treat now
you're stalking cuz I did too whoa you grew up
at Red River till I was 12 I still can't have fish
it's residual trauma just like the smell alone is
is there's a secret lab under the school where
they experiment on kids they're infecting them
with a virus that can kill soups virus are you
sure oh man there's a doct cardosa he he works
in the woods he knows all about it oh God this
is so complicated no I think I trust her such a
for boing feeling Victoria Newman yeah but in
this in this instance like for this situation
I have a platform now where I can help people no
she doesn't get it Marie Maro guardian of gulkan
is marketing okay the first black woman in the
seven she has real power she's friends with the
vice president that's why I trust her cuz she
wants her to survive enough yeah to pass Marie
you have to choose enemy of my eny can't have both
but she's still sending Marie down a villainous
path but in this moment greater good is to keep
like I I think she wants her in the seven [Music]
enough Kate told him the plan called her the plan
you're right what happened I'm okay and now she'll
do whatever we want it's a lie it's totally a lie
you don't have to do this I love you I know you
love me it doesn't change the fact that you're a
[__] oh this school is a front Thomas gulin was
a behavioral scientist he built this place to
figure out what makes soups tick sh okay okay
you're not here to study the school is here to
study you s very clear she wants to make it more
contagious she wants more than that I want it to
spread across the globe and kill all of you oh
my god wow what's a lie what's the truth who side
is who are has she practiced arleny homelander he
took down that plane he kills your family family
you all leave a path of Destruction behind you
look at what you did to your parents jeez ra it
in lady you're going to get killed tell them what
your last assignment was for me kill everybody in
the woods wow she wants to wipe us off the face
of the Earth they all do so we have to strike
first oh that proves their whole point and then
it's shut the Kate andir oh not mom anymore it's
time oh she's got to make oh yeah didn't think
that make it the end oh but she can fix it she can
fix it oh she can't fix it nope not not what did
she just command this is the only way oh my god
oh no overpower you have to let me save her I'm so
sorry you have to relive this oh manly this is so
cruel oh I think Kate was telling the truth guys I
think she might have been yeah no she she pushed
all of us to believe her that's what happened do
you know what you've done Justice oh no it can
survive for a few days at ambient temperature but
you want to get this Tas tubes into co- storage
sooner than later NIH will know what to do oh
he's in the Marvel disu maybe I don't trust her
again you and I we have the same goals right sure
nah she she going to blow your head up dude can
you get me and my family out before things take
a turn already taken care of is this all of
it yeah you're the only one who knows how to
replicate it right you're dead now you going to oh
there yeah you're a 21st century American hero Dr
Cardoza yeah so white oh oh you
must be a little dry oh yeah off
off oh oh I love they solved a mystery from
a boy's episode in this like from forever ago
that's damn damn heads of heads will roll that
was well directed Man very well directed people
America's as reation shop.com just saying guys
they mentioned him here amen mention him here wow
wow the Frau paranoia was just incessant here
I I could not I never knew what to believe I
never knew who to believe I never KN was like the
paranoia was just just Dreadful on all accounts I
think it's like offscreen Development I've never
appreciated more so now that normally normally
I don't like offscreen development stuff but
that cut to and Kate and uh what's her name SK
riched K anded I'm getting better guys K I just
have to make my wether when Kate and Shetty are
are there in the room like oh my God they had a
conversation off screen I don't know which one
the I don't know what like the there's just
a hyper hyper anxiety episode uh it made me
want to believe Victoria Newman yeah it was so
manipulative I was like please someone be on
their side no man Victor Newman bad she bad but
I hope she good to help them because temporarily
good no she's so bad she bad that's the one thing
I've learned from everything in this show is that
anybody above the generation that these kids
are directly in are they're bad people bad what
a great reveal uh that it was her who got her in
there that just makes so much sense and I I forgot
that she her powers not specifically blow people's
heads up it is a blood control Power which i'
forgotten that they set up the powers from Marie
in the boys yeah I should should just put girl I
was like oh yeah her only Power is just blowing
people's heads up but no there's a way that gets
there which I did not put together either when
like she had the same Powers I'm like I'm an
idiot yeah it felt like a revelation from The Boys
Like That season two yeah it's so obvious it's way
too obvious that's what's great is I love when it
twist is so like damn it yes yeah absolutely also
like we're getting a season two of this so it's
going to be boys dealing with the ramifications
of that virus and then going into the further
ramifications of theoretically the seven being
revealed like what's what's a god you school
after the seven revealed not to be great yeah
like so this I I keep saying what a great all year
round show have this half the year that half the
Year this half the year just like cycle deeper
into the world of the boys it sounds like what
they're going to do at least by their [__] key
or somebody was out there saying gen V will feed
into the boys season 4 the four will feed into gen
V season 2 and you know they'll just hand it off
I think he said it's a handoff shared universes
Done Right looking at you other shared universes
well they do such a great job at painting out
the psychology of our characters like it makes
sense whether or not you agree with the choice
of even someone like Sam siding with you know he
was alone manipulated and tortured yeah not these
Trump people pretty malleable yeah yeah not these
Trump people M don't worry guys don't worry I got
it covered rall I'm I'm keeping it real subtle I'm
keeping away from the politics of it that the show
is cleerly not comic books Never Been political
especially this show no and it makes sense why
Kate would ultimately do what she's doing like
at the end of the day she really believes she was
doing the right thing and these are the people
who are the most who who suffered the most at the
hands of ski alri here yeah ski damn you and and
because of that like yeah they would feel like
vengeance is due and they would feel the most
like we we have to have an uprising sure because
look what these these humans do to us they torture
us they control us they experiment on us when
we have all the power and we deserve to take
back the power like I get it I I get it may do I
agree with it absolutely yes speaking as a person
who identifies as powered by S misunderstood
by Society yeah know that was that that was
just really well executed on all fronts and oh why
did Sam have to step outside damn it Sam one rally
one rally Chang just I mean he's like the literal
clay for that exact thing I love that they set up
his anger I love that they set up his fragility I
love he was literally hiding in a closet of like
trying to be isolated and then soon as someone's
nice to him he would be like oh my people and and
that ju opposing what she's gone through like Emma
being scorned but also being a strong person for
IT like she's had the time to build up her sense
of self and like what she believes in so they're
having diametrically opposed views does work but
also they had a lot of the similar upbringing to
the point where they would have a bond not
upbringing but uh isolation and and I I just
love how much like X-Men the powers represent
the fragility of the human psyche like what
their external power is is their internal trauma
and the show's done a really good job of making
the internal trauma externalized through actions
powers and the consequence of the boys and it's
all interlaced with real world issues which is
what Comics do best I think and the way they
handled shett in this episode I thought was very
impressive because the entire series you're just
like is a [__] you're manipulator and then and
then you but no you learn about the family you
learn about and then you know she's telling
the truth to Kate as well andand thing is so
diabolical that that we remember that emotional
reaction to like fall that that was one of like
the most like grippingly harsh Grim moments in t i
i vividly remember seeing that plain sequence and
being like kind of disturbed by the best episodes
of Television period and and I I will admit this
show is so good it made me go back and rewatch The
Pilot for the boys cuz I was like man is it that
I love what the boys has grown and flourished
and all my experience with it or has the boys
been great from the jump can report from the jump
that pilot is but I just had to know and that's
how good they show is that it's making me go back
and like I've seen the first couple Seasons twice
yeah it's a really great show my girlfriend's
never seen it so it's cool to show her I think I'm
going to do season I'm rewatching it with purpose
but I it's so cool to talk it's not for me it's
cool to talk to got a girlfriend between episodes
it's nice to hear what she thinks the show is talk
about it anymore you changed so now that my girl
hanging out with Jack qu so much I wanted to know
what why
you the only three people that have
played supermanman Jack qu Nicholas
the fa Channel but uh it's cool to
talk to her about like the what her
are the show while I'm in real time
seeing the ramifications of like the
[Music]
narrative girlfriend I think it's really cool to
to experience it in a two timeline way and this
show really does a good job like it referenced
a season one moment a season two moment a season
3 ramification it's really good at growing the
world out so I can share it with my girlfriend
yeah she's great great she great by the way
no and and and I'm sure your girlfriend would
appreciate this there's a really good she doesn't
have a name they're really good at depicting uh
the sort of generational Clash I feel like because
especially in the moment in time we live in right
now uh it's easy to kind of look up at all the
authority figures we grew up with and sort of be
like this world is is an ugly horrific mess in a
lot of ways and and you guys could yeah you guys
could do a lot to depending on your perspective
and which war crimes you're okay with how much
you're willing to expose yourself to the truth
take the red pill and which truth you're getting
the truth from which they do a great job too no
yeah all this stuff like it like it does again I
feel like the as that was the thing from the jump
it's like is this going to be you know like really
earned in terms of like how and why they chose
to do this as a spin-off and I think it it so
far really has been nicely that and this episode
certainly kind of gives you that that sense of
like we need to enact a change all these things
are so much bigger than us and it seems like going
through the proper channels either leads to a dead
end or to like the slowest progress that's going
to be set back along the way so like what do we
do with the mess of that Victoria Newman has the
virus mallerie told butcher presumably butcher
about the virus that exists so now so they're
going to want to get their hands on the virus so
we're going to finally have a Newman V butcher
and then but but no but the but the but the virus
would be used on Newman Newman wouldn't want that
virus out there no but like but they would want
to take out homelander butcher also has compound
V in them does it affect people that have injected
it themselves even temporarily but he's got he's
got compound V in in a in a like micro sense
yeah yeah not a also he' sacrific himself well
it depends on how good uh the doctor did his job
and and what kind of contagion level it is can
it you know find that residue uh or be fully ve
yeah that's a good question theories keyword and
Easter eggs break what I didn't really get what
happened but like going back real quick because
like the thing I think they didn't kind of a like
I I like the road mapap of the Sam Arc it's the
one of a couple small things of this episode felt
a little bit rushed as compared to what we've done
in the past a little bit felt quite rushed is
the one thing that felt cuz his story has been
gradual of a time and I think what they depicted
here in terms of you know you can already see the
the seeds being sown of his mistrust of our Core
Group here because Emma you know with his best
interest at heart is trying to kind of conceal him
but with his you know recent Crest into like oh
I'm accepted and this is all so fun and I've also
been to this rally that's completely convinced me
of all this stuff how many kids in college have
that freshman moment right like just when they're
like I've been this and these people love me like
this I mean we see it with there's certain things
that you mentioned and you just get trouble on
YouTube but you've seen it recently with with
certain real life War stuff that's been going on
where people read a few things and then they go
I'm very passionately angry about this now and
they don't really get all the information a lot
of the time not saying what side what side that's
what I mean you already whichever side you think
he said the other one topic it is specify what
it is but but you see that and I think like yes
they have a Lish that he is going to be very
susceptible and easily influenced uh and so I
think they they've planted it it just I think
in context of a shows run time and a rally and
then an episode it feels yeah a little bit of a
conversation I get why the time the CL great and
this is the penultimate episode which is usually
that big like oh my God but it would have been
nice maybe sprinkle that little subplot a little
earlier that that and and dude coming into the
office being like I'm going to give you all the
information you need that really bothers the rest
epod I was like what would I have done differently
you need it like I get it but at the same time I
was like wo Exposition guy it's a functional scene
but it is the one thing I'm like you're oh you're
I'm allowing this because there's like kind of
funny stuff happening but you're better than this
yeah gen V you're better than this because the
rest of the series I'm like I wouldn't change that
or that and then this episode's like okay we got
to have them get this information this guy's oh he
drinks in the room okay sure why not pe's in the
thing cuz it it it serves enough purpose that I
forgive its Sill weird cuz it's it's that thing of
like I feel like this show for the most part has
been well paced and proportioned and now I'm like
should we maybe have done like nine I think yeah
I think Nine episodes been kind of but I think
they I think what they um managed to hide a good
amount hide whatever flaws on upon reflection are
it they they hide it with great um intensity dude
I've been sweating the last few episodes they
get my pals they they hide it with great like
just like fastpaced dread how I put it because
yeah I was I was gripped like the the editing is
super sharp here and you both mentioned the music
and the editing and and every time you pointed it
out it hadn't been distracting but it had been so
good that as soon as I listened for it I was like
oh right that's why I'm G like it's really good
at being subtle until it's like it's like a drum
beat that just gets faster well it kept making me
think of heartbeat CU like I was thinking of like
her blood powers and then her singer blood Powers
come with the third beat John uh I said drum beat
you said heartbeat oh um come ONN pop it off on
you know uh beat by drinks beat Nicks that that
beat Nick energy you know that sort of off the
cuff uh you know a tonal flow it still works you
know I respect the little carow action cartion
there is the carow action of it all and it's an
episode that's rich with development like as much
as those those things I had those gripes it's like
you still get like a bunch of big satisfying we're
not wasting time or dottling kind of development
you don't know who to trust and you also fear for
the choices that that characters are going to make
yeah you see the the kind of comp they've drawn a
nicely complex sort of ecosystem of like oh these
actions are like kind of good in a in a microcosm
but this is going to be a whole mess you even for
Kate like you don't think she's a bad guy at
all uh but you're also like I don't know what
choice you're going to make though yeah Victoria
Newman is so good I kept trying to forgive her for
the things I know she's done I kept being like I
want someone to like here but that's part of the
complexity that the show plays with its audience
it's a it's a little bit of four with the audience
I think I totally agree of like well we don't
want that virus to get out because we actually
like our super protagonist in this show but but
Victoria no we know that she can also do bad like
it's it's there's the complexity there of like yes
we want this to be stopped but do we want Victoria
Newman to be the one with this information right
now also we don't want we don't want them killed
we want them to be held accountable and like while
homelander is killing people in public we do want
there to be some sort of like ramification and
it's it's Jesus and then also seeing and what
I liked about the town hall meeting too is that
like while it was predominantly against Victoria
Newman you would get the voices in the crowd who
are soups like the siren girl who is very much
still like not part of that rally that that that
angry rally uh who was who she's the one voicing
like homelander should be held accountable for
what he did you know and like a fight breaks out
amongst people there and they're all soups so yeah
this is all very fascinating stuff and then like
the revelation of course that God you is actually
a uh the whole time it's not that there's a secret
facility it's secretly a school yeah exactly
like we're studying them the students I think
that that's excellent stuff now what it needs to
do is in the finale get rid of all of its nuance
and I need either a space portal some gry minions
and lots of punching big fight yeah big fight and
less of this talking you think we're going to
get a homelander cameo uh I think we're going
to get at least the boys like the boys and and
we might get homelander and and like uh a couple
soups from the but I I think we might get like
so you think we're going get the boys homelander
and a couple soups train I think homelander runs
through someone again cyclical I think yeah no
but I think either like home uh Butcher and the
boys or homelander or both I feel like we'll get
a homelander cameo yeah yeah it'd be a big Pop
I mean homelander is like the mascot and would
be a great I think conflicting character to throw
into the mix with everybody yeah and especially
now that our our main protagonists know like no
homelander is actually truly evil yeah for the
ey line I think it's more impact I mean dep on
what they do but it could also possibly tease
it a potential Alliance great way for you know
a mega Corporation to use their iconic figure to
make sales up on their show VA Amazon yeah sure
it it works like use the corporate imagery like
you're saying he's the he's the mascot that might
sell even more than the leads of the show if you
have the iconography oh yeah homelanders coming
back I mean yeah in in certain ways I mean it is
sort of the homelander show I me and and two like
not exactly kind of piggybacking off that I think
this will be interesting because I could foresee a
version where this leads to a lot of messy like as
much as I'm like yeah the boys would love this
I'm also like you know though like it is like
diabolical what it is so I can see some really
nice kind of conflicts coming out of that yeah
I don't think you know like I don't think would
be down I think be like let's murder mm you know
even might might like yeah like as much as I got
reasons to hate these people too like yeah yeah
I can't wait no one should have that power no
one man no one man should have all that power
yeah Beats by Dre or the beat next by Dre uh
that said I do hope uh the strike uh you know
everything gets pushed with the boys hopefully
we know Season 4 soon because I I do think the
finale is going to leave us with like a for the
boys like I think it's going to be just shy of a
cliffhanger for season 4 and I know there kryp
key already said like this this isn't coming
out until everything's resolved so yeah what
an [__] this guy fighting for union rights
scab for us man doesn't he know who he works for
Industries what are we paying Amazon to pay you
for yeah $9 certainly pays all of you well I'm
not worry my homelander costume this Halloween
yeah I've been told not to yeah but I will be
West they're going to come to every Halloween
party make I'm just going be homelander from the
comics police exactly yeah exactly get make it
put some like uh find a way to put like a thick
outline around you so that it's clear that you are
pencil drawn and you the comic I'm going to dress
as young Simon Peg and only comic fans will know
that I'm we huy from the comic shave head head
a little bit boom talk an accent guys what are
your predictions for how the finale is going to
go down please go ahead leave your thoughts down
below uh leave a like on this video subscribe get
yourself an America's ass t or anything from the
reject Nation shop links in description box and
pin comment thank you John for being here thank
you Coy for being here thank you for thank you
for watching peace out reject [Music] Nation